hey guys Ryan writes in the hizzy Dan
cyber in Izzy I'm getting requests up
the wazoo to go check out a night to
remember launch cinematic trailer for
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt and I'm liking
the rating so far putting blood and gore
go intense violin nudity moves mm-hmm
strong language strong sexual content
values of alcohol I di di di di di ATI
this sounds like my [ __ ] weekly daily
lifestyle man especially the blood and
gore yeah yeah murder a lot of people I
was gonna say you didn't clean up the
bodies as normally yeah yeah then I have
sex with a body is really strong sexual
content to hear yourself talk sometimes
I hear myself talk every time you okay
ten out of ten one of the best absent
friend
that's honestly in the breeze but one
soul item just why that sound design no
minor who's had some race nice tune
been a while since I heard it last folk
have forgotten it got other things on
their mind
things like me who she's hot they paid
me for you
in times past no amount of coin would
convince a Witcher to take this contract
times have changed
oh yeah all at the [ __ ] sorry buddy just
got a nip slip
just a little bit
sir-sir shots look so real this is
insanity that's a word II out bro thank
you
she jumps into gameplay right now
ah she's not gonna she's a witch
I think
Dampier what's gonna happen
carry something that's what you drink
before I have you sued
you
suddenly don't want her to die
Oh
but when so light
Wow
sold
Oh
slice and dice dude cool that was really
cool one of my first videos on this
channel was watching The Witcher 3
trailer mmm with you and Lauren and I
remember going oh that was awesome like
crow going through head was pretty
awesome and then we watched quite a few
more but like that hands down was the
best one yeah out of all of them it's
just an amazing clip it was so moving
and haunting no like you could feel like
some type of I don't know [ __ ] about
these games but I felt like there was
some type of romantic thing in their
past between him and a witch or whatever
the [ __ ] she was May it probably was a
vampire
yeah I hope we're not wrong about that
well we are per se that will put it as
generic bad press it was interesting
because at first you see her and she's
like oh she's so innocent that no she's
[ __ ] sexy and then oh my god she's
terrifying and she's still terrifying
but I kind of don't want her to die yeah
and then she dies looking like the hot
self and no arms they have unfortunate
how unfortunate and it's a great tease
because I don't know crap about the game
but I immediately made me go I want to
know the backstory behind them I want to
know where he's riding off to when you
get like these cinematic trailers it's
really hard to be like oh this is
definitely a game want to buy because
you know you could have a really good
cinematic trailer but of course it
doesn't rip gameplay it doesn't show
anything and like it can look cool and
be badass and that's awesome however
with this one I feel it more shows off
how well they can tell a story
and that's why I would want to plays
because games like that I could get on
board with gameplay like I'm sure the
gameplay is not
gonna be horrible oh I've heard it right
so to have awesome story to follow along
with those are the games I am most
interested by yeah I know like that's
why I love Metal Gear Solid so much
right because there's like if I'm
correct each game has about 460 hours of
cinematic but about like 30 plot with
yeah better that hooks me in more like
just as a just as a kind of game player
I am what really hooks me is a strong
story those are the ones that keep me
coming back I mean I love like calm like
hack and slash kind of combat or maybe
it's probably not as hack and slash it
I've been playing a lot of blood-borne
and it is very strategic slash you know
slasher sort of game and I imagine
that's what this one's supposed to be -
it's a little more strategic rather than
like go go run and then you go kill
dragon this trailer out of all of them
has been the one that had been like okay
great this is exactly what I wanted the
game what some interesting combat or a
story you're like grab me and pull me in
it lately I'm felt like I've got net
since Mass Effect was like the last game
that I I couldn't put down because the
store because I was just like I need to
know what happens next and so I'm really
interested to see where this takes us I
agree man I agree for realsies I feel
the same way but about like certain porn
videos I know you do you know some stuff
just makes me really sad Pete's delivery
five the sausage eating anyway guys
thanks for tuning into the real rejects
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects no way you
could check out Dan's gaming channel
that cyber channel do it follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where if
we get enough followers we can
potentially get a product placement for
things like watches watches are awesome
sometimes I use a watch like at the
stopwatch um when I'm getting ahead I
like to see how long it'll take me to
come but sometimes I get so focused on
the watch that I start like oh you know
you focus on the time of year and
suddenly like you're unable to compass
your focus on something else but you
know and it's like you focus on coming
then you know come on either so he's
like you really got to be in the moment
so sometimes having a stopwatch gets in
the way but overall style watches work
great to test out how long you can last
for while getting head can't we just
have like really [ __ ] good discussion
on it I'm like one of these episodes and
not haven't followed up by column or
semen or penises this is not right
you're right that's a champ too much to
ask
isn't your champ AHA GOP team assail um
that is a type of food from the Indian
market hey Ryan
big fan I find your channel over a year
ago and have watched every single one
yeah yeah yeah sure even when I'm having
the worst of days but still watch your
videos to cheer me up
oh I was wondering if you could give me
a shout-out I'm an up-and-coming
youtuber who would like to make reaction
videos like you guys and talk about my
dick as well thanks and have a great day
is that it right okay okay you want to
do reaction videos that's slowly fine
with a dick thing that's my thing you
don't you don't do the dick thing dude
you don't do the dicta unless you're
like black wit mitai runs already got
the big dick thing so what man what if
you are male you also have a dick you
don't get it damn girl until I talk
about my dick why it's your dick you
blow I'm not gonna talk about his dick
is his dicks in a promoters Channel
competition hurts you guys just your
[ __ ] YouTube name tattooed on your
penis that'd be great
would be possible people won't reject
this little real reject you know what I
mean